cancel everything on my schedule for the
entire month of September and two weeks
of October and find me apartment enroll
oh my god
and they like panic I believe that each
and every one of us has the power within
ourselves to create the life that we
really want and I want to help give you
the tools to make that happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense come to the pretty intense
podcast today on the show is Bobby Flay
a fantastic chef New York City boy that
made it big and look I went on his show
he's a great guy he's funny he we have a
lot of similar interests and one of them
that came up was his love for horses and
horse racing and oh my gosh horse racing
and and race cars are very similar
I knew that horsepower and horses were
both very expensive but it turns out
they actually have a lot of really
common themes too so we talked about
that we talked about we talked about
things that he's done in his life that
have really been meaningful to him he he
took a trip to to Rome and spent five
weeks by himself so I thought that was
really inspiring so we talked about why
we talked about how he felt about it and
how that maybe changed his life now
after that trip just with just him and
his cat nacho please enjoy when I came
on your show we were talking about the
Kentucky Derby and you even go in there
forever
well I'm a horse racing fan in general I
love horses yeah I own I own breed
thoroughbreds you know in racing they
always say horses and horsepower yeah
are expensive they are very good I have
a lot of horses that are like very slow
but they eat a lot but you know just
cost money
where do they live a lot of them live in
Kentucky in Lexington in horse country
and I especially the ones that I breed
you know that's where the that's where
the moms lived and that's where all the
stallions are and it's a big in the
so do you go to go there very often yeah
yeah I love it there so you like to ride
them to that I know right oh oh I don't
write them though I'd ride those
thoroughbreds not a chance not a chance
in hell do they know how to even walk do
they just know they has they know how to
walk but they really want to run and
they can take off at any minute and I
don't want to go through some fence
Thoroughbred going 35 miles what is that
like what are they what are they what's
their training what's up horses training
for the Kentucky Derby or for the
Belmont or well first of all it's a it's
a it's a it's a long story but there's
about 20 something thousand Falls born
every year in thoroughbred business so
out of those 20,000 Falls 20 of them
will make it to the Kentucky Derby as a
three-year-old there are only three year
old so if they have one shot at it hang
on okay it's only when they're three yes
okay it's not under or it's not no they
can't do it twice I knew there was an
age when I don't realized there was an
only age three years old and you know
that horses in thoroughbred horses all
had the same birthday January 1st why
because it keeps the it keeps the the
industry sort of regulated in that way
so that if you're born if the horse is
born on January third let's say one of
your later on January first the horses
one years one year old if you're born on
December 25th you're one in five days so
it doesn't happen very often because the
breeding is obviously timed in a way
that they're born after January but any
horse like horses are born basically
from January through like June and
they're all the same they're all
considered the same age as two you know
two-year-olds three-year-olds
four-year-olds every every year on
January 1st every horse turns but
another age all horses period
thoroughbreds thoroughbreds on okay and
this is for competing it makes it easier
to just say try you're in you're out
yeah keep track of it mm-hmm and you
have mostly female horses or all female
horses almost almost all fillies yeah
why is that because we're awesome well
obviously but also because I want to
keep them in in my family of
of horses so after their racing career I
can breed to them and then they kept
they can have their babies
so I usually keep the Phillies and sell
the Colts hmm
never had a couple fillies in the Derby
mm-hmm I have not many I mean it's been
a few it's definitely been a lot in the
Derby there's only been a few that have
won it's funny it's a lot like racing
there hasn't been many girls but there's
been a couple some horses and horsepower
so so so many similarities every once in
a while somebody just transcends the you
know you know what people think
mm yeah I guess um and you named it
Sophie right your first or I first was
here daughter my first horse was named
Sophie salad yeah so we salad is she man
you added salad to the end of it no she
loved it I mean she was a kid that yeah
now she's you know an adult so and she's
actually into horse-racing she has her
own horse now and she's totally Intel
does she 23 yeah so will she ride the
thoroughbreds no thoroughbreds are very
dangerous or sissing stay off them
everybody I know that rider gets hurt
everybody oh really yeah
I just I can't afford to you know hurt
like getting thrown from Oris you know
so is it kind of shocking that all the
jockeys are so damn small well they have
to be because there's a there's a weight
requirement Oh requirement I thought it
was just because lighter faster like the
less the horse has to carry the faster
the horses no go no it is but so like
you don't so if if I own a horse and my
jockey weighs 110 pounds and yours
weighs 140 your disadvantage so the the
jockeys have to be very very they're
very lean let's put it that way
okay so there's not an actual rule on
the weight for the jockey it's just
there is an actual common sense there's
an they have to carry a certain amount
of weight Oh
and so depending on its it's a little
complicated but depending on how how the
race is handy like how the race is
graded so in in the Kentucky Derby
friends is because everybody knows that
race they all carry 126 pounds so the
jockeys would probably let's say 110 to
115 pounds jeez are you kidding me that
makes me feel so fat as a girl so here's
what they do so so they
have to carry one I could be a jockey is
what it's saying right so if you won
fifteen and you're the jockey on of a
Kentucky Derby horse you have to carry
126 they give you 11 pounds of weights
to put your saddle okay they do that in
racing - really yeah there was a I call
ballast you know and they would they
would weigh the lightest and weigh the
heaviest driver and then put categories
together of like this weight to this
weight you carry this way this way to
this way you carried this much seriously
yeah so like I always carry the weight
of a driver makes a difference
yeah I mean it's the same thing it's
very it's funny how similar racing and
horse racing are now that you're
starting to tell me all these right
details is that yeah I mean it's you
know when you're talking about the
acceleration speed especially I think
like terminal velocity is not something
where the weight is as critical once the
masses in motion but getting to that
speed the lighter the faster you can get
there really think about getting a semi
truck to a hundred miles an hour right
and then think about getting ya a bike
right I got a crotch rocket to a hundred
miles an hour big difference so I'm
obviously making it really dramatic
about me so when we're when we're
dealing with qualifying times and we're
within thousandths of a second and
hundredths of a second mean many
positions in tenths of a second mean
beginning to the end of the field
sometimes then yeah yeah they I mean
look if it mattered I would have won
every race if it was the most critical
thing right but it's just part of it
right everything counts it all counts
we're talking about Sophie your daughter
and you have a kids show a cooking show
with her right well we just yes well it
hasn't aired yet we just shot it it's
called the Flay list and yes it's um it
actually takes place in New York we did
six episodes so what we did was we
picked six like very cool sub classic
dishes so like like steak and tacos and
lobster roll and fried chicken jelly
sandwich up stick yeah well that's
actually a good one
and then and then so like
I took her to places in New York that
I've been eating that particular dish
you know basically for either my whole
life or like a really long period of
time and then she would then take me to
a place that she knew of that she goes
to probably with her friends you know
that I haven't been to to show like a
you know a different sort of option for
you know basically young people okay you
know so like I took her to this so for
burgers I took her to this place called
JG melons which is like a place of a
anywhere that burgers are good that you
say is obviously off the charts so I
need to know that it's it's the it's the
most simple burger but it's the it's
literally the most satisfying burger
I've I've ever eaten now part of that
could be because it reminds me of my
childhood you know there is there's a
lot of sort of you know mine memory and
- you know equating to deliciousness it
happens a lot like like somebody will
say like I can only eat my mother's
meatballs because that's how I
that's how I remember meatballs are
supposed to taste and then they go to
someplace else like these are meatballs
you know it's the same thing have you
ever been to a shovel in Chicago of
course they opened here they did they
just opened here they're known for the
burger yeah is it good
it is good it's really good super greasy
it's crave always been pretty drunk when
I have to eat it but it's pretty grease
um well I don't mean to get off-topic
but when you said burger I thought Oh
Siobhan Chicago cuz you know growing up
there it's a very it's a it's a it's a
sloppy burger yeah that's what it's
meant to be okay but that's the kind of
burger we like if I eat that burger I
can't use for like three days yeah I do
in the morning it turns out it's
probably cuz of a hangover but you know
I'm trying to I'm trying to catch it
before it really happens at night with
that and the fries and the fries are
totally the most greasy fries so instead
of taking aspirins you go and get a
greasy cheeseburger
yeah or zofran that's the adult version
okay of a hangover cure I'm not sure if
you know about that but it is a nausea
medicine that's like chemo patients use
it but it's it's absolutely the most
valuable thing as an adult really
because if you're sick you take it or if
you're hungover you take it I knew I was
gonna weigh something here today so
you're welcome okay so you take her
you took her around to your kind of
places she took you to her places it's
got the flavor so basically it's oh is
it three and three or is there like one
episode is is you each going somewhere
one one episode is one subject yeah so
so then so she took so I took her to
this place called JG melons which has
been you know around since 1972 I
basically grew up in this place
and she took me to black tap which is
like a very Instagram evil place like
they have all of these like really cool
fancy looking shakes and on and and so
that's so that that's that was sort of
the idea of sort of like old school new
school ah yeah that's cool um there are
so many people that don't know how to
cook
do you think do you agree I don't know I
think that I guess that's my opinion I
should stay I should say this is my
opinion are you good cook let me give
you an example okay I've said this a few
times lately cuz it really made me go
what um look I think I'm gonna go cook
yes but the other night we're watching
basketball and Stephan Curry's playing
and you know he's phenomenal I think
that ninety was sick and Aaron's sitting
there and he's going man Stephan's so
good and we were sitting there about ten
seconds later he goes babe your cooking
is like Stefan Curry's playing really
and I was like what and I think here's
the deal it's because I made him maka
pumpkin chocolate chip pancakes
I'm pretty sure that's why because it
was dinner and that that's what I made
him for dinner and you know was
slobbered with that's been made him
before dinner yeah yeah we love
breakfast for dinner okay
so I think that's probably why but but
ya know I think I'm a good cook I really
do I you know I really love cooking I
really like I'm one of those people that
can just I probably am best when I have
nothing cuz you really have to think
outside the box it's easy to go to the
grocery store and get all the stuff you
normally get yeah and okay it was for me
maybe not for you but you get the stuff
you normal
get you just kind of make your meals
make them predictable make them healthy
but you know when when you've got
nothing left in the kitchen like
especially the fridge you got to dig
deep into the pantry into the pantry and
then there's like leftover stuff like
you know there'll be a potato or
there'll be an onion or Apple or you
know things like that in your word kind
of you know so how do you get your how
do you decide how you're gonna cook like
do you look up recipes online you get
you just look at a potato and decide
where you're gonna make do you have that
those abilities yeah that's great yeah I
watched about a million episodes of
chopped and thought what would I do
great and then I went on and I won it's
like jeopardy like people lose stay at
home you know like I can do that but
it's not easy when you get there right
Oh James you finally lost you do just
short of Ken Jennings two point whatever
million two point five something or six
million they need to have a pay-per-view
showdown do you think that's a great
idea book it right here we won't air
this episode until that's happened so
that no one else gets the idea no that's
a great idea but it's so speaking of
Jeopardy Aaron's really good at jeopardy
really yeah yeah I'm good at cooking and
he's good at Shepherd I'm not go to
jeopardy I am not good at jeopardy I did
one night when I was in Indianapolis for
the Indy 500 I was I was one of the
broadcast team shift in position and and
my parents and I were watching it and I
was like all right collectively let's
see how we can do and like Erin can get
like 20 right really on its own
we got 12 hmm three people we got 12
right yeah it's hard I mean I you know
when I watch it I'm like this is so like
speaking of Education I said you know I
don't think enough people know how to
cook do you agree with that or not you
know agree with that not enough people
know how to cook I think it's growing I
think that I think especially in this
country I think the interest in food has
really grown over the last 10 or 15
years and I think people are a lot more
interested in cooking and they're doing
it in lots of different ways
even like these um like these at home
meal kits that you can order like a
printer yeah yeah just teaches people to
to get around the kitchen a little bit
more even if they've they're given a
head start
it's still teaching them how to do stuff
and of course you know now with all the
incredible information you can get
online and yeah just you know how to you
look you know how to do something you
look up look it up on YouTube and you
will find it and so I think it's
empowering people to cook more for sure
do you ever do that what go to youtube
absolutely you do yes because I have to
be like you did my show so I have to be
sharp because there are gonna be I just
did v I just yesterday finished my 50th
episode this season so we've done 50
episodes so so you master fifty other
people's recipes no I didn't master my
gloss a bunch of it how many I was 29
and 21 really yes you 129 and 129 look
okay I'm usually in like 65 to 70%
success rate but but there's plenty of
times where you know somebody some
people say a dish and I'll be like I've
never made that before now that said I
don't what I do is when I'm can't sleep
in the middle of the night like I'll say
like I don't know a lot about like Thai
cuisine let me look up a couple of like
classic Thai dishes and just get a sense
of what they are and like you watch
people do it on YouTube and you learn
yeah you know it's like you know Thai
food is not my son I go to you know
everybody has their lane you know but I
have to be ready for anything and not
that I'm gonna make it perfectly but if
I can all my my goal is to just to be
able to complete it and make it taste
good that's it and then it's up to the
judges
it's why do you say that because when I
was on chopped look um who is the other
Amanda beard maybe or something she's a
swimmer and she was she was really good
like she knew how to make homemade
almond milk which yes I know how to do
that now but like the point that point
in time I didn't know how she knew what
the names of certain things were she
knew how to like
look like a certain way to chop certain
foods and then put it together was
called something I'm like look she's
above my head with her knowledge and
culinary so what I said to the judges
was you have to enjoy what you're eating
look at the end of the day if you don't
like it it doesn't matter doesn't matter
and I want cuz you got it like that so
you cohorts the judges is what you're
saying and I slipped him a 20 - I did
and then a hundred after that cuz it
didn't do it they're easy to buy they
were really nice they were really nice
so do you think that there should be
more Ron do you think there should be
more education in school like do you
think that do you think that like the
home acts sort of like cooking classes
on all right do I think so yeah I I
definitely think so I dropped out of
high school I saw pop hi yeah I dropped
on high school too did you yeah I'm GED
me too yeah you know I can't went to the
same College we have the same degree no
but I have another acronym
okay I'll hear that I feel good enough
diploma you gotta have diplomas so I I
used to you know I'm from New York and
and we used to hang out on Lexington
Avenue and that that's that was that
that's we hung out in what does that
mean we hung out in Lexington is that
like so cool place is this like you know
not that was a cool place just just
where we were was it was it's so
different now like literally there was
like 40 to 60 kids hanging out on a
street corner every single night it was
like me saying when I grew up we hung
out up we hung out outside the Mobil gas
station yes exactly it was the place
that you like this will read it exactly
got it but it's a picture in a street
now that doesn't happen anymore cuz like
they basically don't like kids do that
anymore no I think we got bothered one
time by the cops
I didn't mean to move along yeah but
anyway so art so I always just say that
we went to UCLA the University corner of
Lexington em and like so when I say that
people like UCLA you went to UCLA like
not really good yeah so so I think that
they should teach cooking in schools
more a hundred percent I think
I think we need more vocational
education period because when I was in
school I had zero interest of opening a
textbook zero I don't know I don't know
if I was intimidated by it or I just
wasn't interested in it but I didn't
happen I don't think you're alone I
think that uh a lot of people don't I
didn't look I was good in school I
didn't study
I always got like a 3.5 or above I just
like but I didn't ever study and I
didn't really love it and in fact I
asked my social studies teacher in fifth
grade what the point of the class was
because I just didn't get it but now I
want to learn I think they I think that
school is all messed up I think that
when we go at the wrong age but anyways
yeah but I'm not interested in opening a
book I agree and the first time I became
interested was when I quit school and
went to work in a restaurant as a cook
and I started working with my hands and
then I actually got interested in life
right there that's how it started life
in general I was interested in anything
really I was just a kid hanging out in
the street corner did you find that you
say life that sounds pretty pretty
transformative oh yes so well there's
something to be said for being inspired
enjoying life and being positive well
look what the food business has been
able to do for my life it's it's opened
up so many doors and and it's opened my
eyes up to the world I mean the one
thing that I'll never forget there's a
guy who handed me a check for my college
do it for my culinary tuition the day I
went to school mm-hmm and he said to me
I'm doing this because I want to oh I
worked for him he said I'm doing this
cuz I want so you don't owe me anything
I just want you to remember something if
you become successful as a cook you can
take this anywhere in the world and
apply it and it and when he said it to
me it didn't really register but now I
know that anywhere in the world I go to
I can go anywhere I can go to Italy I
can go to Thailand I can go to Russia it
doesn't matter I can walk into a kitchen
not speak their language and then cook
with them mmm which is amazing it's kind
of like math you could do it anywhere
math is math cooking is cooking yeah I'm
not good at math but I could mean either
I'm not good at math but I could but I
can definitely cook it so like I like
last year I did something that I've
always wanted I'm obsessed with Italy
like I I try to I want to in my mind I
want to live the Italian lifestyle tell
me because I've never been there
okay so when I go I need to know all the
deets all right you need to spend a
little less time in Green Bay and a
little more time in Rome I mean I agree
I'm sure you're fun it's like celibate
way I can get Italian wine somewhere
iced I took last year right around this
time last year I was on the Amalfi Coast
with some friends and the Amalfi Coast
you know it's right on the Mediterranean
and it's where like Capri is that
Positano all these beautiful well I'm
get to a point no I'm not I'm not
humble bragging brag I love it so
hanging out my friends and we're there
for about a week and I remember sitting
in my bathing suit drinking an espresso
looking at the Mediterranean and I
called my office and I said ladies
cancel everything on my schedule for the
entire month of September and two weeks
of October and find me apartment in Rome
oh my god and they it was like panic
because they were like you have a full
schedule I was like if if it's not
important we need to postpone it I said
I need to do this for me Wow
and this last year yeah and I took my
cat nacho and we went to Rome for six
weeks just just I was by myself and
completely by myself and I had the had
no plans except I was gonna live in a
room and I signed up for Italian classes
for three and a half hours every day
like in a classroom with a bunch of
people who are from all over the world
Wow and and I went and I you know went
to eat lunch and dinner every day and I
walk into the restaurants and I would
talk to the chefs
and then they would invite me to come
and cook in their restaurants and it was
an amazing experience because my
business I have to say that I really
feel like the food business
the restaurant business is the most
generous business period we are
competitive but we are we have amazing
camaraderie amongst us globally so like
when when another chef comes into my
restaurant he's given like the red
carpet experience like we send out food
to them we buy their dinners whatever it
is it's very give-and-take I feel this
way about the wine business I make wine
yeah the same your competitor for one I
think the food and beverage businesses
are very much like that and I don't
speak Italian I can get by when I'm in
it when I'm in Italy hmm but it didn't
matter because when we were all cooking
together when I was in their kitchens we
spoke the same language with at the
stove yeah so I feel like I feel blessed
that I have that skill what made you say
I'm not leaving I have to stay here was
there a moment did you have an epiphany
he's a big dramatic decision Italy yeah
well I was there but I can and then I
came back because I was there in June
and then I came back for a couple of
months and I got my act together and
then I planned it I plan to not be there
for like six weeks and everybody all my
friends all the people that work with me
they were like he's there's no way he's
gonna last not a chance he's gonna lose
his why would they say that yeah and why
did they say that because just because
like you know because I was gonna be by
myself yeah I thought I'd get lonely and
they thought that I would you know start
missing New York and and and have a hard
time frankly more importantly staying
away from my businesses which I had
never done in my 30-something years of
being in business sure and so I just
said I have to do this and here's what I
found out I found out that first of all
it was one of the best five or six weeks
of my life I found out that I don't have
to work to be happy mmm and that reach
and that I can be I can find interest in
so many other things
other than what I'm doing today and I
could be alone that is one of the
hardest things for people to do yeah and
you don't know it until you do it what
not for a long weekend for like real
time yeah what did you were there some
things that you figured out about
yourself in that time span of being
alone with nacho that that you didn't
really realize or that emerged and
you're like man that's been sitting
there forever I didn't really realize I
was into this or needed that I I think
that it it made me well first of all it
made me realize that and and most people
will tell you this that the European
lifestyle is so much more relaxed than
the than the American lifestyle yeah
like they you know I'm surprising it
picked to be in Italy in August don't
they take all of August off well you
couldn't have worked in the kitchens
then if they do all take it off exactly
I well the whole point is is that they
get up and they go to work you know to
live we live to work it's a different is
a completely different adrenaline yeah
and listen I'd love to work but I think
what I realize is that I'm not a
workaholic and that I do what I do
because I really care about it and I
love it
yeah but I can also not do it the
difference is for somebody like me I'm
lucky I really feel lucky because when
I'm not cooking professionally well I'm
not in my restaurants or cooking on TV
or writing my cookbooks the thing I do
to relax is cook like you'll be the
guest you'll be a guest in my like I
cook I have a house in the Hamptons and
I cook every weekend I I look it's I
literally run a hotel it's a free hotel
but it's a hotel and I have my houses
with my perfect I'll be there fine my
house is my my house is is filled with
my friends and yeah and you know Sophie
my family yeah and I cook three meals a
day every every single day and I'm in my
bathing suit though so it's totally fine
and it's a
different pace but I love doing that I
love nourishing people I love cooking
for people it's the way I show my love
mm-hmm
what was the difficult part about being
in Italy was there any was there any was
there any like look in the mirror [ __ ]
that happened that you're like mmm all
right I've been pushing this one down
like did anything get deep or difficult
or was it just pure damn joy
honestly Danica I was in Italy I was
cool I liked it it didn't
not I I a bunch of people I saw a bunch
of people I knew there because the one
thing you realize is that when you're in
Rome like people roll through Rome yeah
yes so like people would call me be like
I'm there let's have a drink let's have
dinner I'm gonna be there on Thursday
night and and people kept saying to me
over and over this is the happiest I've
seen you in a long time it's good here
yeah it's great and they were right you
know I just I kind of walked around with
like this perpetual smile on my face I
was relaxed I wasn't stressed out if
something happened in the restaurants I
couldn't go cuz I was there so is it was
it made it'll my decision-making was
yeah it was made for me you know I feel
like especially Americans you're talking
about obviously the difference in
culture between Europe and America and I
totally agree I lived in England I've
travelled to Europe and I feel like we
we're working our asses off like a badge
of honor we're like I worked more than
you I didn't even take a vacation I know
it's true it's true it's true when I
lived in England everybody took a
holiday oh yeah everybody every year you
always took a vacation and I've done it
ever since then were you there from 16
to 19 for racing that's why it's a high
school dropout right my junior year I
left halfway through and lived there for
three years and so I came back when I
was 19 and I I think maybe when I was
like 20 or 21 like I took my sister to
Bora Bora I'm like we're going on a
vacation a holiday I think it's a good
rule olia take time for yourself yes so
did things change when you came home as
far as like look out of sight out of
mind with your business a little bit you
got some perspective on you know you
don't have to work to be happy
working more does not make you more
happy it's not more rewarding and yeah
you know did things change when you came
home definitely I mean I think that you
know I I mean I've been opening
restaurants since I'm 25 years old so
and there's oh there's always been sort
of something on the board like that's
coming up next and I'm not doing that
anymore
like I'm really focusing my business
life a lot more than like where I don't
I don't feel like I need to conquer
everything in the food world and and the
food world like your world has changed
so much in terms of media and stuff like
that that you know for like the last 20
years like it's like you wake up in the
morning and it and we'd be sitting
around my house sitting around my office
and it's like Disney World is like what
phone calls gonna come next which is a
really nice thing I mean opportunities
right it's a champagne problem but but
the best thing I always tell people is
that the best decisions I always that
I've ever made are the ones I say no to
and I think that I'm sort of adding that
I'm adding more nose to the nose that
were already there and I'm just good I'm
just a lot more focused and I don't need
to do a gazillion things I just had this
conversation with my girlfriend last
night about you know this shows starting
she's like wow have you since you're so
happy and I told her I was like you were
right a couple of years ago when I was
freaking out in my head cuz I was
retiring and I was like I've got to get
all these projects going up gotta get do
this and I've got one last platform to
tell tell my story or watch whatever I
want to do and you're like she told me
hey slow down like don't rush it it will
come and I told her girl you were right
you were totally right and now it's
taken a year and a half and you know
this show this podcast has come together
really quickly but I'm like here's the
difference to me when you do things and
I said this exactly this is the exact
thing to her I said when you do things
when you're really busy doing things
that you love to do you're energized
when you're really busy doing things
that are not true to you you're drained
that's true
I was busy as hell yesterday but it was
an amazing day and I couldn't go to
sleep I was like full of energy
and so I think that's a really good
barometer and you know you obviously
display that when you cook for all your
friends in the Hamptons like you are
energized by cooking no question about
it
like I would gather that you know most
successful professional athletes face
that moment of retirement and your and
everybody's a young person when they
retire in the sports yeah and you know I
guess you're concerned about losing
relevance right I mean that's that's
really the you want to be relevant
you want to continue your relevance I
think that's what the ego says the ego
says I want to be relevant but I had to
listen to something that was more
meaningful which was I want to be
inspiring and I want to be impactful and
you have every opportunity to do that
like when Marcus who I said I
interviewed he was like who's a show for
and I said it's for me this show is not
for a specific person because I could
screw that up I don't know you I don't
know that person I know me though so I'm
gonna make this show for me and the
hopefully the the crowd will show up
that's like me but I think that's really
cool that you came back and you said
look this is me I'm gonna focus on what
I want I'm gonna do the things I enjoy
I'm going to Hamptons to cook for my
friends cuz I love that because that
fills me up and I love these restaurants
and I love cooking I must stay here not
gonna worry about launching another
product or another another show and
because look there's a big difference
between a TV show about cooking and
cooking mm-hmm that's true
and I I think that I've been able to
continue I've been on Food Network for
25 years and I continue to evolve I'm
always I'm always the same person but I
continually evolve what I'm doing there
and and what my approach is to to food
and I listen to what people want and
what they what they yearn for in terms
of in terms of food because that's
that's my lane you know and they look to
me for inspiration and ideas and and I
and and I
stand that that's part of my job well
the network's not been around all that I
mean how long is the network been around
it's been around for just over 25 years
yeah yeah I mean I've been here since
the beginning yeah the founding father
one of them
speaking of father um like food industry
is crazy right I mean just I was a
waitress for a hot second and I'm good
I was terrible yeah that's a good thing
you don't you know you don't need to be
the best waitress in in America that's
for sure
thank God I didn't need that skill
because when they didn't like what came
out I was like no you didn't tell me you
wanted the sauce on the side and you
know I I'm argumentative it's are you at
my sweet spot yeah I can be that way and
then we weren't allowed to talk to the
chef for some reason in the restaurant I
worked in like you weren't allowed to
talk to the chef so I'm like [ __ ] how do
I ask for something specific that this
customer wants without getting in
trouble
but look that it's it's tough like
you're it's you know you're it's late
nights it's you know signing in just
nights of days it's prep that's I mean
there's a lot so you know what's the
balance like like how did you did you
feel like it was out of whack most of
the time or did you feel like you found
a groove was it was it bad back in like
was it really difficult in the beginning
and good now in terms of what just uh
family balance Oh family yeah yeah I
mean I think any any sort of like
high-powered profession is gonna have
you know issues Balam balancing like
personal life and business life just
because it takes up so much of your your
brainpower and it takes up a lot of you
know in the case of what I do it takes
up a lot of your physical power as well
so you know listen I I've been working
14 to 16 hour days every day for my
whole life and so yeah it certainly it
certainly makes personal life more
difficult do you think like is there
someone that can understand that yeah of
course yeah yeah I look I yeah I
never make a blanket blanket statement
or about you know it can you can you be
successful in the restaurant business
and also have a personal life of course
you can it's it's it's difficult to do
and I think you're right I think you
need to find the right person but you
can send about anything you know that's
all that's all anybody ever talks about
is like finding the right person in any
situation yeah well look like you think
that the in the cultural standard or
paradigm of relationships that's there's
this assumed role of you know how much
time you're supposed to spend together
what you're supposed to do what you do
in your free time and like the older I
get the more I realize it's just um it's
just a man-made construct it's just a
human construct of what's acceptable and
it doesn't have to be like that like you
can go take a guy's trip girls can go
take a girl's trip you don't have to do
every single last thing together like I
mean I grew up with two parents like my
parents did everything together so that
was my modelling I'm like that doesn't
have to be like that and so you can you
know you can have some to things that
you love and so for me I talked a lot
about like the macro balance and the
micro balance like the in all in life I
don't think it's possible on a micro
level like right now you're not with
your family or you're not at the
restaurant
you're talking to me yeah something's
out of balance what's that a balance
yeah well you're not doing something
else so you know even if it takes a span
of time of like you dive in for a month
on something because you're starting up
a restaurant or something like that like
it's out of balance but then you know
what maybe the month before it wasn't in
your home a lot or you know some kind of
like one of those people it's like look
at the macro look at the big version
look at the totality of it and you know
the ebbs and flows don't have to be in
one particular rhythm they just have to
have one yeah I think the I've been
really lucky I have one kid and you know
she's now she's an adult she's 23 and my
relationship with her is the greatest I
mean like we are friends besides the
fact that I'm her father
I mean there were definitely lines that
she can't cross
still at 23 absolutely hang on you
called her a doll but then you said
there are lines yes what does that mean
what it means is that she actually hangs
out with my friend group I mean okay
Sophie is amongst us always because
everybody loves her and she's cool she's
cool in all of us and we always want to
be around her but at the same time you
know she's still only 23 and she still
needs to be parented and you know does
she agree with that she does she does I
mean she you know she's she's done you
know she graduated from from school in
May and she already has a really good
job out in California she's a reporter
for ABC come on
and so she's doing exactly what she
wants to do and she's a go-getter but I
think that one of the things I was able
to give her as a kid growing up in the
restaurant business was I gave her
exposure to besides the fact that yes
she has a great palate and she'll she'll
eat anything that was just exposure okay
I love that only a chef could describe
their kid like that yeah she's a great
palate she's a great palate she really
cares about food she really she's not a
good cook she doesn't spend a lot of
time cooking but she loves to eat and
but even way more important than that
she ran she grew up running around my
restaurants and she saw she was she
wasn't aware of it then but just
basically through us mostest more so she
she saw people working really hard
enjoying what they're doing and smiling
and so as soon as she got old enough to
understand that work was something that
was gonna happen
she wanted to go to work like if she
didn't love school so much College she
would have quit and gone to work because
she wants to work based on her childhood
watching people in my businesses really
love what they do
hmm I love that it's like a paradigm
shift you know within an industry that
has a bad reputation not an industry not
cooking but working right people think I
gotta go to work
why can't you work the awesome right I
think feel like that about food you know
people like healthy food is so terrible
I want the ice cream I want the pizza I
want the whatever I'm like why it's it's
all good
it's all good I love my work I mean I I
never do I complain about work yeah cuz
I'm a human being but basically I that
almost never happens
I love what I do for a living I feel
really lucky and it's it's it's not just
my work it's my lifestyle yeah yeah you
know even when I'm like even when I get
even when I go away to get away from it
all and go to go live in Rome for six
weeks I'm still like in my apron cooking
at somebody else's restaurant because
I'm so attracted to it would you say
then that your time in a house like your
home or Rome home your Hampton home
whatever like is that your self-care
time is cooking yourself here time 100%
when I get out - I I've had this house
in the Hamptons and for about ten years
when I get there my entire body shifts
like I feel my body like it's almost
like it drops down like a notch I sleep
longer I sleep sounder it's just it it
it's it's I could feel my body body sort
of healing itself is that some is that
is that like a time when you think to
yourself why do I do anything else or is
it this is really good for a little
while every now and again like what is
your ideal yeah right you need both I
need both like I I mean I do relaxing
things like this is great but I'm bored
now you know we're like I need something
rewarding or something you know like I
want to go accomplish something that's
kind of what I said in my head like I
need to go accomplish something
ya know I need both for sure but I
combine them all time like - like what
I'm done here
one of the things I have to do is I have
to go shop I have to go to Whole Foods
and shop cooking brunch tomorrow morning
for 20 people in my apartment because
I'm taking them to the Belmont Stakes
how cool and frankly like I can't let
them eat at the racetrack
is it this weekend long oh it's tomorrow
yeah there are the races on Saturday
probably the big races in mostly on
Saturday so it's a as in New Yorker it's
a big tradition for me to take a bunch
of people to
takes everyone so I so what happens is
is it's an all-day affair so I cooked
breakfast for them in the morning they
come in they're like everybody's all
suited up so link they come to my house
at nine o'clock in the morning I feed
them I put them in cars we go racing do
they get mimosas tomorrow morning it's
gonna be it it's it's a tangerine
tequila spritz of course it is
I forgot drink the mint juleps yes I
drink I drink one mint julep well let me
go back I'm a huge bourbon lover yeah
so I drink bourbon neat or with like one
ice cube or something but every year
right before the Derby when I say right
before I mean like two minutes before
they're about to go into the gate I
haven't met you up it's sort of
something I do
I don't care Moni yeah it's a ritual
yeah you're good just look you're sweet
but they're good
you like them conscious or really yeah
horrible jeez drink bourbon no what do
you drink wine well your fancy I'm sorry
what you grew up in like New York I mean
the guy I got no way I have to open you
your alcohol horizons a little bit yes I
mean Aaron likes scotch yes so he pilots
Bourbons yeah yeah yeah um that's fine
mint julep it on so they come over here
20 people over and you cook for them
then you take them out and we go racing
yeah and then and then after racing we
go to a steak house ah in New York so we
go back and we so they don't eat during
the day they just drink a bunch of and
then I have to feed him again well if
you eat too much it's hard for it to
really be effective the alcohol yes
that's true why is that
absorption I don't know yeah it's a
thing though right yeah for sure
yeah absolutely it really bums it I'm
such a lightweight now though I was
gonna ask you know um so you had a of
Bobby Flay fit yep you had like more of
a healthy hmm cookbook book and why do
you why it's probably the question I get
asked almost the most damn it I try and
be original no really wanna know cuz I'm
super into fitness
you know no not that question but like
people ask me how I as somebody who's
around food all day how do I stay in
shape sure yeah and so you know if
listen health and fitness is a huge
subject and people they want to feel
good they want to look good you know
and so I I wrote a book about it's a
cookbook and but I talked I talked a
little bit bit about my sort of rules of
life well what are they well a couple of
things number one is when I go to a
restaurant I don't eat everything on my
plate I eat three quarters of it so it's
like the seventy five percent rule it
makes a big difference twenty-five
percent list yeah
number two is if I don't like something
I don't eat it which is something that
people do all the time do I got they eat
it even if they don't like it yeah so if
it's not good I'm not gonna finish it
I'm not gonna eat it yeah and and I
think one of the biggest ones for me is
I don't eat late at night which is
something I used to do when do you have
a time that you stop at or do you just
there's not a time I don't have a few
hours before you go to bed but it was it
was the hazard of my industry has my
yeah where like you get off at 11 or 12
at night yeah go we'd go out eating and
drinking until 3 o'clock in the morning
and then go to sleep the worst the worst
the worst so I don't do that anymore
I mean every once in a while of course
but like that's a lifestyle shift that's
a big lifestyle I don't like the word
diet I think that it's yam complete
[ __ ] and it's a it's a it's a quick
fix
mm-hm and so yeah you can find some
fancy diet or some diet that says don't
eat this or eat that and then you're
gonna lose you know 12 pounds in 45 days
right but you know what happens yeah
yeah you go back because it's worse so I
always I mean my hope with my book
because there's there's recipes or
there's a workout program there's
there's the mental side of things too is
like your pancakes in there yeah I don't
have the chocolate chips in them but
they're and they're okay and is that I
wanted people to stop looking at it
as a diet basically like what you're
saying like stop looking at is a
temporary thing I said if you want if
you if you
you do this program for 90 days and you
eat this way and do the workouts you're
gonna lose weight period like you just
are but what are you gonna do after that
so people if any if anyone were asked
I'm sure they would say I want to look
good for life so you got to figure out
how you're gonna make you know why are
you gonna do it that's gonna last for
life not like I want to lose 12 pounds
because you can but we live in a we live
in a quick-fix environment yeah it's
like everything has to be done quickly
press a button to make it happen doesn't
work that way in health yeah I think
there's a I think we're going back in
time I think the days of like quick food
and fast food and processed food I think
it's going I don't know I get if I feel
like we're getting more of that
farm-to-table kind of local ingredients
and ingredients with integrity I don't
know I see that a lot in the restaurant
world it's a it's a good thing because I
think for a long time there was many
decades where it was all about the
faster the better and food means
something to me I'm I I can't throw
things away because once I've made it
I'm like I put love into that yep can't
throw it away um all right well what do
you do for work out son
do you work out or is it just a matter
of like I'm mostly a runner I've run
four marathons and I so I run I I ran in
high school for the short period of time
I was there so when I saw you walking
five blocks here when the driver dropped
you off at the wrong place you're like
oh this is easy
yes yeah I walk off I walk being
actually living in Rome for six weeks
like you can walk the city it's a
walking City you walk it I could walk
the city every day the entire city it's
it's great it's a great [ __ ] city but
New York is the same way I walk to my
restaurant to work all the time takes
about 25 minutes to walk it's great it's
amazing a sweat you you get going makes
it be looking that far but I'm a runner
I run along the West Side Highway a lot
and and the last five months I've been
doing yoga really mm-hmm well tell me
what are your thoughts
my thoughts are that it's good for my
head and you know it's good for my body
as well but it's really good for my head
I would agree
I'm a very type A go go go go go if I
have to choose between CrossFit and yoga
I'm like CrossFit you know like if I'm
gonna burn some if I'm gonna take the
time to do something athletic I'm gonna
go all the way you feel like you're
getting something out of it yes you can
see it feel it yes exactly but when I do
yoga I get done and I'm like I need to
do more of that it's good for my head
too I think that you know the breathing
I think would probably just
underestimate the breathing like as
human beings were shallow breathers we
have a lot more capacity and the calming
effect is over I mean you could take one
two or three deep breaths and feel
better I could could literally sit here
and just take a deep breath like I mean
that feels better
why don't you do it what just now cuz my
my my yoga instructor instructors always
yelling at me to breathe better it's
like well it is a is a difficult
practice to get the breath and the most
very oh yeah I took me a decade they're
really like oh you match it you know and
match my pace which the problem is class
is dictated by the teachers pace not
your pace so it's really nice when they
like I do
I love vinyasa flow classes so you know
when they give you a mini flow at the
beginning of the class and then they
give then they're like alright go
through this you know do it three more
times on your own that's what I love
because there's a real rhythm to that
but have you dipped into like the
meditation side of it at all like have
you kind of not like I know she vaasana'
always feels good but that's kind of the
progression of yoga as you end up
realizing how good it is for your mind
and then you go okay next level is
absolutely doing nothing and just
sitting here and quieting down and and
it's a practice like it's not like you
sit down and you see you know you get
some like divine messaging every time
you sit down or like feel like you're
floating when you're done but the the
ability to slow down resets the day so
well and I'm saying this because I wish
I I'm like like reminding myself to do
it more
but you know maybe that'll be somewhere
where you get but I think we're similar
in a sense of like going going neat
knowing that we need some some balance
but like gogo kind of people so you do
meditate I do not regular for how long I
mean this is the problem is when I do
something I like to go all the way so I
I look I look at meditation like if I do
it for five or ten minutes nothing
amazing happens I'm not gonna bother
with that so unless I have at least like
30 minutes like I could probably get
into meditation almost be there for an
hour
like when I get off on it enough like I
could go full hippie and do certain
breathing exercises first then get into
some visualization breathing then sort
of slip into the more meditative spot
where you're really kind of shut down
and then after that I might like do like
cards like pull a cart have you have
like Angel cards or you know they're not
tarot cards but I don't know you know
sort of intuitively and kind of go
through that and that whole process
could take an hour and I really enjoy
that but damnit when do I have an hour
come on I know I need to make more time
you do i how you how are you going to
what do you do to fulfill your your
competitive nature uh so with racing I
mean I was
yes I'm competitive but yes I am
competitive I mean but I think that the
success of a business is the mark of you
know is the mark of success right so you
know if I do the show people listen
that's the competitive side of me the
ego wants to have tons of people
listening and and resonate with what I'm
saying to me that's the competition is
like how can I get more and more real
and honest and vulnerable and true
myself so that I can share on a level
that people will will it will resonate
with them like that's the competitive
challenge it's with myself yeah
everything is with yourself you know if
you said this fight probably had so much
fun and in Rome by yourself because
there's once we become our own best
friend everything else is just icing on
the cake it was also cool because I
didn't get recognized there almost ever
yeah
and I can go to a bar by myself sit and
have a cocktail and know what he's like
what are you doing here by yourself yeah
something that people you know kind of
forget about with like the world of
being recognizable is that like the
regular stuff like even just like going
to a concert
oh yeah or yeah I mean like that kind of
stuff gets going to the grocery store
like how you look
Oh looks like a slob today she looks
like you know I mean Jesus really you
know it's it does I mean look there's a
lot of added benefits you know when you
look when you walk onto the jet you're
like okay most people don't do this yeah
you know but you know it's it's there
are other sides to it so I can
understand why you know Rome was really
a good place for you well I hang on I
have two questions okay so I read that
you said never send food back I didn't
say that you didn't scratch that okay
never eat airplane food I said I would
never send food back but like I just
because I would never do that to
somebody in my business I would never
want them to feel like that I was
setting that I as a scheffers are
sending back food to a chef but if you
come if you came to my restaurant and it
wasn't what you wanted whether it was
undercooked or overcooked or whatever it
was and you weren't happy with it I
wouldn't want you to send it back 100%
I wanted my dressing came on the salad
and not on the Sun that 100% yes is that
like would you send that back if that's
what you wanted no if that's what you
wanted wait cuz that's not saying the
food's bad it's just saying well you get
what you want yeah like I'm a I mean I'm
serving my customers they're there they
actually made the effort to put their
clothes on get into a taxi you walk into
my restaurant yeah sit down and take out
their credit card so like I appreciate
every single person that does that cuz
it could stop tomorrow I don't well I
don't want them for one second to not
get exactly what they want respect that
yeah I don't put it's confusing why you
wouldn't send it back because
the this is just a little courtesy there
okay you know is it like because you're
a chef yeah because I wouldn't want well
first of all I wouldn't want some other
chef saying I and Bobby Flay came to my
restaurant he sent my steak back to me
you believing that I mean like look I
don't ever send something back if I
don't like it that's just a preference
but like a preparation that I asked for
send it back but usually I'm a total
diva and I asked for sauces on the side
and things like that I'm like you know
especially with us Sam why do you do
that uh for I mean look I work really
hard as far as choosing the right foods
working out and the last thing I want to
do is have like a gallon of fat and
sugar and salt sitting on my food when I
don't need that flavor like I'm I like
simpler things and it's healthier that
way so for me it's about my body mm-hmm
okay great
yeah but see I watched the movie waiting
have you seen that no Ryan Reynolds
about sending food like it's the it's
called they work at a restaurant called
shenanigans okay that's funny if you
send food back let's just say it doesn't
it's not pretty
okay got it and so the first time I ever
watched
I think it's called waiting I watched it
that night went to dinner and my salad
came with the dressing on it and I sent
it back and I was sick for like two days
really yes
fact well I can say right now like no
restaurant that I know of does anything
crazy like that that's that's it that's
to meet your Bobby Flay though I'm not
sure I was at a Bobby Flay restaurant
you know it's much more who's probably
below that and then uh airplane food
what do you what what um you know a lot
of people ride on airplanes I don't eat
it period is there some insightful
reason I just well it's it's not fresh
right I don't know how long it's been
sitting around and there's alternatives
the alternative is you eat before you
get on the plane or you can bring like
something that's packed
that's good for you like like yogurt or
something like that like I don't I can
get by not eating on a plane for a few
hours I'll be okay
that's a better alternative in my mind
yeah
the answer is always no and and the and
the flight attendants always joke with
me and they're like I knew you weren't
gonna eat I'm like well okay I mean if
you say that you're like you can have my
meal and they're like I'm good I'm good
[Laughter]
okay well like okay that was a bunch of
nose but so like give us some give us
remedial cooks a few like tips for the
like things things to always do when
you're cooking for people which should
you always make sure that you keep in
mind it could be from preparation any I
mean a couple things I think it I think
it's important when you're cooking for
other people to cook within yourself so
cook things that you feel like you can
really cook well yeah experimentation is
great I think it's better in the you
know sort of in the privacy of your own
meeting yeah you know what you're
testing new things yeah kick them around
and so I always say to cook within
yourself I think that the best way to
cook for people especially if you as as
the cook want to be part of the party as
well is to cook family-style so just
make platters of food as opposed to
trying to plate everything for everybody
yeah so like in my house like if I'm
making like I make fish tacos a lot in
the summer because I go to the fish
market I'll buy three different kinds of
fish I'll make one marinade for all
three and then I'll make different
salsas and relishes and tortillas and
stuff like that I'll just put it's
almost like a taco bar I put it out yeah
it makes it easier yeah in terms of
service you know yeah so I think that
that's you know should make it easier in
yourself I actually I have to cook a
lunch today I have a business meeting in
my apartment and I and I I just said
I'll cook lunch and frankly I have no
idea I'm gonna cook yet you have any
ideas structure making pancakes
pancakes or waffles easy I have some
duck in my refrigerator so I might make
a duck pasta or something pasta yeah
yeah I think about duck I think about
like a little sweeter like a Chinese
five-spice almost sort of salad almonds
makes millions yeah good good duck
confit salad can you make that from I
guess today sure I have to either well I
I mean after 1:30 I'll be late to my
thing tonight but you know but but I can
make it wait to my thing tonight mmm
thank you so much Bobby
my pleasure appreciate it
[Music]
you
you